-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, I'm very excited
about this.
Demi Lovato
is my co-host tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Come on.
-Yep, last week, I co-hosted
with Megan Thee Stallion,
and now Demi Lovato.
Yeah, I'm gonna --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm gonna get worried
if NBC says, "Okay.
Now let's just try it
Megan and Demi.
Jimmy, you get out of the way.
Yeah."
[ Laughter ]
Let's get some news.
I saw that since the FBI's
search of Mar-A-Lago,
former President Trump
has been scrambling
to put together
a team of experienced lawyers,
but everyone
is turning him down.
[ Laughter ]
Trump needs to be careful.
If he says, "I'm desperate"
three times in a row,
Rudy Giuliani will appear.
He's like, "Showtime!"
[ Laughter ]
But Trump's offer to lawyers
is pretty enticing.
He's like, "Sure, we'll probably
lose, but I also won't pay you."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Trump's
pretty depressed about it.
Tonight, he was on the couch
working with the law firm
of Ben & Jerry.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the other big
political story is that
Representitive Liz Cheney, who's
on the January 6th committee
and has been outspoken about
Trump's defeat in the election,
lost her primary race to
a challenger that he endorsed.
Trump was so excited,
he threw a ticker-tape parade
made out of
classified documents.
He was like...
[ Laughter ]
"Celebrate good times, come on."
In her concession speech,
Cheney promised to do
whatever it takes
to ensure that Donald Trump
is never again
anywhere near the Oval Office.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So she's installing a ramp.
[ Laughter ]
"These shoes are very slippery."
You guys see this? Today,
CDC director Rochelle Walensky
said that the agency didn't
respond quickly enough
to the COVID pandemic and called
for a reorganization.
Yeah, the CDC said that they
didn't responded quickly enough
to the pandemic.
They might be on to something
because everyone was like,
"Sorry. Which of the current
pandemics are you referring to?"
[ Laughter ]
♪ We're cool for the summer ♪
Guys, you know what that means.
It is time for my amazing
co-host for the evening.
Demi Lovato, come out here!
Demi! No!
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Oh, thank you!
Thank you so much.
-Come on, now.
Oh, wow.
I didn't even get
a standing ova--
-Thank you.
Oh!
-I didn't even get
a standing ovation like this!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Thank you so much!
-[ Laughs ]
Thank you guys so much.
Jimmy, I was wondering, can I
join you for your monologue?
-Of course.
I'd love it.
But there's
so much going on right now.
I mean, there's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Today, Rudy Giuliani
appeared before a grand jury
in Georgia to testify about
election interference.
HBO is about to debut
its "Game of Thrones"
prequel series,
"House of the Dragon."
[ Cheers ]
-Doctors are telling people
to stop doing a TikTok challenge
where you tape your mouth shut
while you sleep.
[ Laughter ]
And Capri Sun recalled
thousands of drinks
because they might contain
cleaning solution.
-Yeah, there's a lot to go over.
Let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
First up,
Rudy Giuliani is in trouble.
He's the target
of a Georgia investigation
into election interference.
[ Laughter ]
When he found out,
Rudy shouted a bunch of words
that you can only say on...
-HBO.
[ Laughter ]
They're about to debut a huge
new "Game of Thrones" prequel
called "House of the Dragon."
It takes place 200 years
before the original,
and it's a great idea, unlike...
-Taping your mouth shut
before you go to sleep.
[ Laughter ]
People are doing it on TikTok,
but doctors say
it's bad for your health.
Kind of like...
-Drinking Capri Sun
spiked with cleaning solution.
They've recalled
thousands of drinks,
not to mention those pouches,
which can often...
-Leak. Rudy...
[ Laughter ]
...does it all the time.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now he's under investigation
by the state of Georgia
and the feds.
I mean, there's no way that guy
is getting much...
-Sleep.
[ Laughter ]
Come on, TikTok.
Mouth tape, tortilla slapping,
the face-wax challenge.
Seems like the only thing
y'all don't allow is...
-Nudity. "House of the Dragon"
will have lots of it.
So fingers crossed
none of the actors look like...
-Rudy Giuliani.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I mean, just look at that face.
That guy
could definitely use some...
-Cleaning solution.
[ Laughter ]
Drinking that would be gross.
Almost as gross as...
-Hooking up with your sibling.
[ Laughter and groans ]
It happened
on "Game of Thrones,"
and it could happen again.
But I'm excited for the dragons.
They breathe fire.
And so will you
if you swallow...
-Pine-Sol Capri Sun.
[ Laughter ]
So, in conclusion...
-Ice and fire.
-Total liar.
-Nighttime ouch.
-Clorox pouch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now...
All right, get this.
I read that some scientists
think that we should start
naming heat waves the way that
we have other natural disasters
so that people
take them more seriously.
But I'm not sure
naming them is a good idea.
Take a look at this recent
weather report I just saw.
-If you're in the Midwest,
brace yourselves
'cause Kayleigh is coming,
and she is hot.
Extremely hot!
Experts are rating Kayleigh
a scorching hot 10.
Way hotter then Jemma,
who has been downgraded to an 8.
Kayleigh's only expected
to get hotter
as she moves toward L.A.
Jerry, this feels wrong.
-Yeah, yeah, that's interesting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It just feels wrong, I agree.
-Wrong.
-It does.
-Some business news.
Airbnb wants to stop
big gatherings at houses,
so they're rolling out
new anti-party technology.
-Oh.
-In a related story,
Airbnb just went
out of business.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's too bad.
They had a good run.
Switching gears,
everyone loves TikTok, okay?
But sometimes you just want
to skip the boring parts
of a video
and get right to the good part.
Well, it turns out you can.
There's a new thing you can do.
For instance, if you're watching
a video, you can skip this part.
-And go right to this.
-Cheers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Dude, that was me.
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
-Here's another example.
You can skip this part.
[ Both laugh ]
-And go right to this.
-So I got these new boots.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's me.
-It's so everybody.
Guys, this is very cool.
Adidas just unveiled headphones
that are powered by light.
Yeah.
No charging cord.
No replacing batteries.
Just the sun.
It's very simple.
All you have to do is,
step one -- wake up.
Shoot, it's raining.
[ Laughter ]
-Step two -- dig through your
junk drawer for batteries.
-Yeah, step three -- put
the batteries into a flashlight.
-Step four --
shine the flashlight
onto your headphones
for 8 to 10 hours.
[ Laughter ]
-And finally, step five --
enjoy up to two whole minutes
of music.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Awesome.
That's awesome.
-Just two.
-That's it.
Well, this is wild.
They said that scientists
are working to bring back
the Tasmanian tiger,
which went extinct
almost 100 years ago.
-Yeah, scientists were like,
"We brought back
Taco Bell's Mexican pizza.
We can bring this back, too."
-Yeah, science is amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Demi, thank you again
for doing this.
We're all so excited.
Now, I know that you're busy
with your new album, "Holy --"
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Holy --"
Well, we can't say it on TV.
Let's just call it "Holy F."
[ Laughter ]
-But that's not the name.
I mean, they gotta know
it's "Holy F--"
-Flamin' Hot Cheetos.
[ Laughter ]
-No. No, it's "Holy F--"
-Frank Sinatra.
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy, come on.
Don't be silly.
IT'S "Holy F--"
-"Friends" on NBC.
[ Laughter ]
-"Holy F--"
-Fuhget about it!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Holy --"
-♪ First, I was afraid ♪
♪ I was petrified ♪
[ Laughter ]
-"Holy --"
-Family.
When you're here, you're it.
That's Olive Garden.
Unlimited breadsticks,
amazing soups.
So many things.
-Jimmy, enough.
You can say it just once.
I promise.
They told me it was okay.
-Really?
I can say the title?
If you say so.
[ Clears throat ]
Demi's new album,
"Holy F--"
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
-We've got a great show tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]